so where i had left off is we had this
circuit we had these little leads here
this was kind of our innovation and this
is actually called a commutator where
these this part that's connected to our
rotating piece that's the commutator and
these are the brushes so they kind of
you can imagine you could design them as
brushes that always stay in touch kind
of like the brushes on a um
on a uh what was that a uh what are
those cars at the amusement park bumper
cars right on the bumper cars you have a
pole behind your bumper car i'll draw
that for fun so let's say this is your
bumper car
looks like a shoe a little bit this is
you driving your bumper car
and they have a pole and at the top of
the pole you'll see these brushes that
are touching the ceiling right you could
view that as the same type of brush so
what it allows is a constant electric
current
to flow through the ceiling i'm assuming
i don't know what direction it's going
in but it allows a current to flow
through the ceiling and maybe your car
is grounded so the current can flow down
to gar on so that your car could be
powered by the ceiling and not have to
carry a battery in every car which would
be kind of a waste of energy and
probably some type of a health hazard
and safety risk etc etc so those brushes
on your bumper cars are not too might
not be all that different from the
brushers that are the brushes that are
touching the commutators here just a
little bit of terminology and never
hurts to introduce bumper car references
probably should have done them earlier
when we were learning about momentum and
things
but anyway
so what was happening here so going back
to our first video we have the current
going down like this
and then if you use your right hand rule
with the cross product you know that the
net force from the magnetic field is
going to be downwards on the left hand
side upward on the right hand side so
you have a net torque rotating it like
that rotating the right out of the page
the left into the page or into the video
screen up to the point that you've
rotated 90 degrees and now you're
looking kind of so this side right here
let me do a different color so you can
see it this side
is this side
right on top and this side is on bottom
below the page this side is now above
the page right if this distance is r
this side is now r units above the page
and i said ideally maybe your your
commutator loses touch with the brushes
at this point right because they're
popping out a little bit so when you're
vertical they actually lose touch with
the brushes so you have no
you have no circuit flowing so you save
a little battery energy and you just let
a little bit of the angular momentum
carry the whole this whole rotating
contraption um further a little bit to
the point that you are your
configuration will look like this
so i know i keep changing colors but
where the whole contraption
will now look like this
well now
okay
and that's my positive negative positive
negative current flows like this now we
assume that the commutator has gotten
back in touch and i just want let me
color code this so if this side is this
color
right
then this side now this is what we're
looking at top on where it's popping out
of the screen where it's above the
screen and now we've rotated 180 degrees
and this side is on this side
right and if this side let me pick a
suitable color if this side was green
now this side we flipped the whole thing
over 180 degrees
now something interesting happens
remember before we had this commentator
and everything if we just flipped it
over
the current
because before when we didn't have the
commentator the current here was was
flowing up was flowing down here up here
and before the commentator we had the
floor current flowing down here and up
here and so we were switching directions
and so you would have had this thing
that would never completely rotate it
would just keep flipping over right
which may be useful for i don't know if
you wanted to flip things but it's not
useful as a motor
so what happens here now this side all
of a sudden inside instead of being
connected to this lead is now connected
to this lead and this green side is now
collected connected to this lead so
something interesting happens now the
current on the left side is still
flowing down
right and the current on the right side
is still flowing up so we're back to
this configuration except that this
contraption has flipped over the brown
side is now on the left and the green
side is now on the right and what that
allows is that those net torques are
still going in that same rotational
direction use your right hand rule the
current is flowing down here
so if your magnetic field is coming to
the left
then the net force is going to be down
there and it's going to be up there and
so we we can continue indefinite and and
we solve our other problem that we will
never keep twisting these wires here so
now using the commutator we have
essentially created an electric motor
and remember i drew that little thing
that could be like the axle maybe that
turns the wheels or something so if you
have a constant magnetic field
and you just by using this commutator
which as soon as you get to that kind of
vertical point it turn it cuts the
current and then when you go a little
bit past vertical a little bit past 90
degrees it switches the direction of the
current so on the left hand side you
always have the current coming down and
on the right hand side you always have
the current going up so that the net
torque is always going to be pushing
is always going to be rotating this
contraption
down on the left hand side and up on the
right hand side
coming out of the page on the right hand
side and then down on the left hand side
and you could actually turn you know
turn a wheel now you could create an
electric car so that is the basics
really of of how electric motors are are
created i mean most electric well
there's another way you could plan you
didn't have to use the commutator one
methodology you could have used is you
could have had the magnetic field going
until you get to this point and then you
turn off the magnetic field right and
maybe you wait for
the this situation to go all the way 180
degrees and then you turn the magnetic
field back on again right that's one
possibility but that's you know maybe
not as efficient because half of the
cycle you're you're not powering it or
maybe you switch the direction of
magnetic field or another option you
don't have to use a commentator maybe
you use some other contraption to switch
the direction of a magnetic field but
this is probably the simplest way to do
it and i think it gives you a general
idea of how a ma electric motor can be
created and then we could play around
with the mechanics of of
innovations on it but all electric
motors are essentially some variation of
what you have learned in this video
isn't it neat to learn something useful
see you in the next video